will what's up
hey guys sorry i have myself muted
what's going on not much how are you
friday
good good uh first week of class this
week pretty much just uh syllabus week
so didn't do much but uh
hanging in there with the school stuff
but other than that man interesting week
in uh bitcoin so ready to get into it
we're gonna get into bitcoin but we want
a school update first we saw a tweet
where you were in class and they were
teaching you about a 60 40 portfolio uh
and you were laughing what was going on
it was you know i was cringing inside it
was tough uh to sit through that you
know learning about uh you know
allocating allocating your money to
negative yielding bonds isn't really
exciting to me uh but you know it is
what it is at least i'm enjoying my
history class
all right let's jump into on chain
metrics first up is we have the total
supply held by long-term holders what's
going on here
yeah so um you know last week and
following this week we've reached new
all-time highs and uh the amount of
bitcoin that long-term holders possess
um you know which is obviously a really
good sign because long-term holders
historically kind of set the floor
um you know when you look at this as
just a percentage of circulating supply
it's about 68
67.7 if you want to be exact um and then
when you use uh instead of circulating
supply as the denominator if you use
adjusted supply
which is factoring out lost coins
and so just for listeners glass node
just uses a seven year threshold so over
that they consider those coins lost
and so using that as the denominator
you're looking at eighty four and a half
percent of adjusted supply
but yeah so the point is you know
long-term holders are buying like crazy
here um not only that but
they're also um
we're also seeing short-term holders
aging past that
that 155-day threshold
and that's that's shown by by huddle
waves
so what you see is that um in the the
smaller portions the younger portions of
of coins so you know when you look at um
below six months
those are going down while you're
starting to see a larger portion go into
those uh you know three to six month uh
six to 12 month one to two year uh
cohorts so you're starting to see not
only just once and holders buying here
but also you know the investors the
entities that came on the network you
know
you know three to three six months ago
are now starting to age into that
long-term cohort um so the combination
of both of those things is why you're
seeing this new all-time high
got it and so when we start thinking
about the short-term holder long-term
holder percentage we're seeing basically
the exact same thing right
i'm sorry would you say
the short-term holder long-term holder
percentage is basically the exact same
thing
yeah exactly it's just um you know
looking at
the the percentage of supply held by
long-term holders both in terms of
circulating supply and the adjusted
supply
all right and so we've got the realized
cap hodl waves explain to everyone what
this is and then what are you seeing in
the actual numbers
this is just
illustrating that not only is it
long-term holders that are buying that's
contributing to the to the increase in
their in their supply but also cohorts
that are aging into that 155-day
threshold and so you can see that here
with the hotter waves that you know the
smaller the smaller um i should say
younger cohorts are going down while the
older ones are moving up so you're
seeing the aging of those coins into the
upper threshold so for example you know
a coin in the in the one week to one
month threshold is not moved so now it's
moving into the one month to three
months and etc so you're starting to see
strong maturation which is a good sign
people are coming on the network buying
their coins and holding them strong
spent output age bans
yeah this is just looking at um
different different cohorts of age and
the amount the percentage of outputs
that that came from that specific cohort
that makes sense so what what i have
been looking for
is you know are these long-term holders
taking exit liquidity that would be
concerning to me and we did actually get
a spike up to like 18 and 0.75 percent
um you know this seems to kind of been a
one-off thing
and that spike was really in in three to
five year holders in two to three years
as well um but since then that that's
cooled off now that you know we're back
down to 3.4 as as of yesterday so
it seems like so far that that that was
just you know a one-off thing that some
of these longer-term holders were
briefly taking profits but just watching
this closely to see if you know uh if
this kind of becomes a trend um
on tuesday i sent out a newsletter and i
basically just said hey look you know
i'm feeling kind of cautious here when
we had this you know failed breakout
about 50k kind of rejected there um that
in confluence with seeing some coins
coming out to exchanges a drop in a
liquid supply and then also some of this
uh selling from longer term holders kind
of taking profits on into the rally
which isn't completely unexpected um i
was kind of suspecting we saw some some
short-term uh you know price correction
uh and we did go down to about you know
whatever 46 300 but um it seems like we
kind of found a local bottom there i
tweeted something about that yesterday
but now today it seems like uh jay
powell has kind of given us the juice
to maybe start heading back upwards
we're also seeing a tick back up in
both the exchange flows so coins are
moving back out of exchanges again um
and then also the liquid supply has
moved back up so um kind of the concerns
that i have there and in the letter i
sent out tuesday have kind of been
alleviated the entity adjusted asol uh
seems to be showing a pretty rapid
recovery as well uh last couple of days
yeah this is
very similar to the spin output h bands
it's looking at once again like the
average age of the coins being sold and
so
what you don't want to see here is what
you know if you look at back at uh late
2017 or early 2018 you see that big
spike after all-time highs when we start
it's a little off because it's a moving
average but that that spike really came
on that on the dead cat bounce which is
actually a little bit to the right in
the chart uh but point is you know once
again you don't want to see everybody
jump ship it's not you know it's
completely expected to see people taking
profits on the move up um but you know
don't want to see everyone just sell out
at once uh and so you know you'll see
all the way on the right hand to the
screen we're starting to get this move
back up in a sole but
you know kind of just monitoring this
day-to-day want to make sure we don't
see any massive move up in that to that
would tell me that you know everybody is
abandoning ship kind of like late 2017
got it and so then when we start to look
at uh things like the futures dominance
obviously this shows how much kind of
leverage is in the system or is one
indicator of that um explain what you're
seeing here
yeah so
most people like to look at funding to
say okay you know funding is positive so
price has to go down funding is negative
so price has to go up like i think
there's a there's a little bit more
nuance than that um so like funding is
slightly positive
which in theory you know when you have
prolonged positive funding that tends to
be a bearish thing when you have
prolonged negative funding that tends to
be a bullish thing um but that doesn't
necessarily mean every time funding is
positive price is going to go down or
vice versa you know we had like six
months of prolonged positive funding uh
towards the you know late last year
early this year um you know there's
several things here to kind of unpack
like firstly
funding is although it is slightly
positive it's nowhere near where it was
earlier this year at similar price
levels
um also you know when you look at what
you just mentioned about the open
interest dominance this is just
comparing open interest to market cap
and just taking like a basic ratio of
that and so when when open interest
really is insignificant compared to
market cap the odds of futures having a
real effect on the price is is lower not
to say that it's impossible that we get
a squeeze but i think the chances are a
lot lower than many people are saying um
also that the red line that in the chart
you just had popped up that's the uh the
leverage ratio so it's just looking at
open interest compared to
how many coins are on that specific
exchange to kind of get a ballpark as to
like how collateralized traders are uh
both of these things are still kind of
mild so um i don't think we get any
crazy you know uh short or long squeezes
got it and then when we start to
actually go into like net realized
profit loss or a realized profit
realized loss um you've got this kind of
four part chart uh what what exactly are
you looking at here what are you seeing
yeah so in the top left you have the net
realized profit loss so the difference
between the two um on the right and the
top right you've realized profits bottom
left realized losses and then bottom
right is the percent of addresses that
are in profit so
what i'm looking for is you know like we
touched on earlier it's to be expected
that you're going to see profits taken
on the way up that's what happens in
bull markets long-term holders
distribute into strength um but what i
don't want to see is is the overhead
supply start to come onto the market
and so
you know we had this really large
distribution zone between 50 60 k and we
trapped around for whatever two three
months before we started moving down um
and
what you don't want to see is that
overhead supply store to come onto the
market and add in additional cell
pressure so i'm watching realized losses
to see if those coins from above are
starting to to move down here um which
doesn't seem to be the case it seems to
be mostly just realized profits which is
a good sign
also the percentage of addresses and
profit is kind of important because you
know the longer that the longer that the
market stays below people's cost basis
the more likely they are to capitulate
um in theory so the fact that we've gone
up from 69 at the lows to 86 percent of
addresses non-profit is a really good
sign
um yeah i'd like to see continuation of
that and then like kind of on a similar
note looking at sober this is once again
looking at the profit taking of coins um
we're back above the one threshold which
means the market's trading in a state of
profit which is once again a really good
thing um and so this is the weekly
version that i threw in the newsletter
but also if you look at the daily
version um we got to bounce off of one
uh whatever two days ago when we had
this little mini correction uh which is
a good sign because it's showing that uh
investors aren't willing to sell out a
loss so kind of using those things in
tandem but still prairie is a good gauge
to say okay like are our investors um
you know are market participants willing
to start selling at a loss do they want
to get out of the market that bad it
doesn't seem like that so far because of
the we've gotten to bounce off of one
twice over the last two weeks
got it and then when you start to look
at the transaction uh volumes i know
that at one point you were a little
worried because it seemed like the
number of transactions was uh trending
downward it seems like those are
recovering
um
like slightly but i'm still a little
concerned about it because it's it's
pretty much just ghost town i mean we've
gotten off the lows that we were at like
you know last month but when you look at
like the transaction fees which is a
good uh kind of proxy for like uh you
know block space demand that s continues
to move down but the number of
transactions and also the active
addresses that this kind of moved up a
little bit but still nothing that that
you know
the way i worded in the newsletter was
we've had a big swing in price but no
dang yet and transaction activity so i
want to see some follow-through on that
and some people have been saying that
it's because of all that you know all
small transactions are moving to
lightning network which is possible but
um you know i think
there's no real way to exactly quantify
that so
it's hard to say and then also
we are seeing really strong highlighting
behavior so you know it could partially
have something to do with that people
just don't want to transact their btc
and we're just seeing people you know
buying and holding their coins like
when you think about the network do you
think of you know this is just a
rhetorical question for listeners do you
think of usage of the network as
transactional activity or do you think
of it as hotline right um i guess some
people have different answers so people
say it's a combination of both um i
personally think the bitcoin networks
you know considering usage of it would
be huddling and if you think of it that
way you're seeing usage of the network
at all-time highs but if you are
considering it um using using
transactional information then we are
kind of in this uh kind of stalemate
ghost town where you know it is a bit
concerning to see and something you
definitely kind of want to see pick up
over the next couple weeks if we get
more price continuation
makes sense exchange net position change
basically how much bitcoins on the
exchanges versus not what are you seeing
yeah so we got another little dashboard
for chart thing here uh top left like
you said is the net position change so
looking at the 30 day change between a
month ago today and now uh top right is
just a raw balance on exchanges bottom
left is a balance on coinbase bottom
right is balance on finance and so what
you see is that um exchange flows had
gone kind of flat uh and then the
newsletter last week um and the one i
set out tuesday was suggesting caution
was when we had started to see net
influence exchanges
which once again suggested that people
had started to take profits on the rally
um and then about
two days ago we saw this down draw in in
balance exchanges again and looking at
the individual different exchanges uh it
looks like that that's coming from
coinbase so you'll see in bottom left
that draw down in coinbase's balance um
i think it's roughly 30 000 coins but
don't quote me on the exact number uh
bottom rate is finance and what you see
is that finance continues to increase in
terms of how many coins are on the
exchange so uh you know you're seeing it
what looks like selling from from the
east and then buying in the west uh or
also some people could could consider
this kind of a way to gauge like you
know people are moving coins on to
binance for speculative purposes because
binance has leverage and all kinds of uh
you know products that you can get you
know speculative leverage on anything so
you could see it that way as well but
generally like when you you see a lot of
selling in in uh asian hours and then
buying in in like the early morning uh
eastern hours so
i i think that's probably more more the
explanation but that's just kind of a
theory
got it and then when you look at minor
profitability as the last thing here
what are you seeing on that
yeah so
you know
we just had this difficulty adjustment
and so when you have more hash coming on
the network which by the way is just
slowly recovering um nowhere near where
it was a few months ago but you know
it's it's been uh recovering you know
slowly grinding up and when you have it
when you have a difficulty adjustment um
the miners that are still you know that
are on the network uh they become less
profitable um
so so what you see is in in this uh
green line that that's the revenue in
bitcoin terms per hash and so after the
difficulty adjustment uh whatever two
days ago um you saw a drop down in that
but yeah hash is coming back up which is
a good sign as well
got it and so like this you know it
makes sense why miners have been holding
their coins because they've been more
profitable lately right uh and so
i'm curious if maybe we start to see a
little bit of miners trimming their
holdings because they'll be less
profitable over the coming weeks but
they still are way more profitable than
they were even two months ago but you
know as as that hash starts to come back
on you know
the miners are competing more so for the
same amount of block reward then you're
gonna see that the revenue uh per hash
go down
if you had to kind of summarize how
you're feeling right now
bearish
neutral bullish how do you think of
yourself right now
well yeah i'm leaning kind of neutral to
bullish because we had an uptick in uh
the liquid supply shock ratio and then
also like i mentioned some of those
coins moving back off of coinbase which
sometimes uh it can take a few days for
the heuristics to update so
wouldn't be like 100 solidified on that
but over the next couple days we'll get
confirmation to see if it sticks or if
you know that trend continues but as of
right now i'm i'm leaning at least
short-term uh bullish for sure um
the only thing that's really concerning
me is is the transactional activity um
you know it is really low relative to
what you usually see in a bull market
but some people say perhaps you know
that's just like a
um you know a following factory um you
know
you see the price increase and then the
transactional activity follows but we
did just have a big move over the last
couple weeks so i would be expecting um
you know more follow-through than that
so
something definitely to keep an eye on
over the next couple weeks
got it joe john you guys got any
questions yeah i guess
well my question would be around uh just
some of the metrics that you you look at
right and i think uh most people expect
kind of based off of your evidence that
you've presented on chain and some of
the other stuff going around that the
price is going to appreciate here uh
over the next few months
uh some people think more rapidly than
others but i think everyone kind of
generally understands that's invested
it's going to appreciate do the metrics
change and like what metrics do you look
at as we start accelerating and as we
start getting uh the price starts
accelerating towards 100 and all these
other numbers do those change or do you
look at the same metrics
no yeah it's a great question like the
way i think about it is um you know
on-chain is just a toolbox and so you
know for different circumstances you use
different metrics um you know for
example like you know two months ago i
was looking really heavily at what
miners were doing because of the chinese
minor migration and uh we had really low
volume so you know
it didn't take as much cell pressure to
move the market at the time so seeing
some of that cell pressure for miners in
my opinion uh contributed to some of the
downward price pressure that we had so
like you know when we get back into a
regional bull market i'm not going to be
looking at what miners are doing as much
because that that cell pressure pretty
much just becomes insignificant compared
to even like the exchange fees that are
being sold onto the market although uh
brian armstrong
did say they're going to put 10 of their
their profits into into buying crypto so
that's a good thing um but anyway yeah i
would be looking for
um you know what's going on in the
futures market i think like for
short-term price movements that'll
become more prevalent as we probably
move up for now i think like the futures
market is probably
just just remaining cautious until we
get that you know uh
a solidified move perhaps over 50k or
over like the 1 trillion threshold or
whatever these traders are looking at
but for now it looks like the market's
mostly spot driven
as we kind of looked at like oi
dominance so that would be one of the
things i'd be looking at as leverage
starts to come back in if we get a price
move up
because that'll play a bigger role in
kind of the the market structure
john
will did you say 85 percent of the coins
are held by whales or bigger entities
oh yeah so 80 it's 84 and a half uh i
just have to be smart-ass
because of uh
when you're looking at the adjusted
supply but when you're just looking at
circulating supply it's 67.7 um but
either way you want to cut i mean they
the long-term holders own a very large
portion of supply
when you talk about whales
that's another interesting conversation
like when you plot this out over time
what you see is that whales distribute
their coins throughout bitcoin's history
while retail as a percentage of overall
supply increased their holdings um and
so you know if you had some theoretical
genie coefficient for bitcoin it would
be moving in a positive direction
because you're having that healthy
supply distribution over time
well where are we going man what do you
think happens to the rest of the air you
still uh pretty bullish on a much much
higher price
yeah i'm still uh after this after the
data updated last night i'm no longer
you know short-term bearish i'm leaning
more neutral to bullish over the next
week or two
um you know technicals it looks like
we're perhaps setting up for a
volatility squeeze here and in that kind
of same time frame as well so
um you know looking for that in the
short term in the midterm you know i
still think we need to get over
whatever 50k or the trillion dollar
threshold um that that gives the capital
on the sidelines kind of that
confirmation
um and then for like from another chain
perspective i talked about like some of
my my top and bottom price models um the
the kind of bull market uh threshold
that i'm looking at is right around 60k
so if we did get up there it'd probably
line up right around when we
theoretically break off from highs
because it's slowly trending up uh but
if we were to get over that then i would
be targeting you know whatever the the
next uh
part of the models i think it's like a
95 95 okay
so yeah and in the short term though
like
um watching some of those things we
touched on earlier um you know it is
with this data you kind of just have to
take it day to day and watch how it's
coming in um it's you know once again uh
kind of hard to to predict several
months out but i think just anecdotally
hearing some of these things from from
people that i know who have some you
know connections in the space and the
capital that's supposedly coming in
towards towards the latter half of the
year and just kind of the seasonality of
bitcoin i think i think we're still kind
of set up for for more upside here um
you know
something we've touched on many times
with broader metrics uh really never
really reached any kind of overheated uh
you fork zone um kind of resembles a lot
of stuff in 2013 where you kind of ran
up about halfway and then came back down
and and then went up and reached those
uh kind of euphoric uh you know blown
off top levels in some of these macro
metrics so watching some of those things
um
also one other thing we didn't touch on
which is just kind of a side note
the the percentage of futures that are
margins by uh by stable coins versus uh
bitcoin so like this has been an
interesting trend that you've seen since
may 19th where
now you're seeing a lot of traders
preferring to use uh stable coins as
margin instead of bitcoin which kind of
makes sense because um a lot of traders
got wrecked on may 19th and seems like
now they're being a bit more cautious um
you know if you just think about it
right like
if you're margin with bitcoin and the
price starts going up well not only is
is the price of the asset that you're
that you're betting on going up but also
the margin right so like if if you're
betting that bitcoin's gonna go up your
long bitcoin and you're margin with
bitcoin well bitcoin's price is going up
so your p l is going up but also the
margin of that position is going up so
it creates kind of this reflexivity up
uh but then also on the way back down um
you know it can be bad because your your
collateral is going down in value and i
mean in tandem with your with your p l
so it can kind of create this convexity
on the way down and kind of accelerate
moves down and that's kind of i suspect
played a role in that drawdown that we
had in uh early may so
the the good part of seeing uh you know
these stable coin margin features is is
in theory
um they're more susceptible to getting
squeezed shorts are more susceptible to
getting squeezed because
right like if you're short and your
margin with bitcoin and the price starts
to go up yeah like the trade is going
against you but also your collateral is
increasing right because you're because
you're margin with bitcoin and the price
of bitcoin's going up so
[Music]
the fact that they're that they're
margin with with stable coins uh takes
away that kind of like double dipping
you get where if you're short uh you
know the trade starts to go against you
you're still uh you know
you're still benefiting partially
because your collateral is going up so
you're not as as uh suspected to getting
squeezed
um so yeah like i think i think i think
seeing like an increase in stable coin
margin features um is is somewhat
bullish in theory because you have
people that are
more susceptible to getting squeezed
than normal if that makes sense
it makes a ton of sense and i i think
this all goes back to like the on-chain
metrics don't lie and also what's really
fascinating is you saw some metrics
change but you actually waited a couple
of days to
understand how they were going to play
out and so it's not something that you
can necessarily trade on immediately
because you could get faked out by
kind of the real-time nature of it but
if you understand the right cadence of
how to internalize this stuff synthesize
it uh allow for enough time to really
have confirmation and a trend change or
not then you're able to apply this stuff
and understand where we are in cycles
both in the short and long term
yeah 100 like if you're using like
exchange flows and you're tracking that
intraday like you're going to drive
yourself crazy well you know the
heuristics they're not perfect right so
sometimes it takes a few days for them
to update and um you know i think if
you're using this stuff on like some
kind of like you're day trading off of
it i mean you're just kind of setting
yourself up to get wrecked uh like you
just said it's it's best used you know
over a you know
week to two week on a time frame um and
you know especially with the exchange
balance stuff and some of the some of
the entity labeling um you need to wait
at least a few days to kind of wait for
that stuff to update and also see if
it's a trend um because you can drive
yourself crazy one day you know the
exchange balances go down the next day
it updates and it's up so that's like
you need to wait at least towards the
end of the week you know see is there a
trend like you know when i said that
when i sent out the letter tuesday that
exchange flows were
increasing that was like a week-long
trend that they had moving up so i felt
confident in putting that out but
you know like this this uptick i mean
this downtick in exchange balances um
from coinbase yesterday um i'm still not
fully confident in that and that's why
i'm like a little bit hesitant to be
bullish for the like the data in itself
like the downtick and exchange flows in
the uptick in liquid supply ratio that
is bullish but i'm waiting a day or two
you know to kind of see if those
heuristics kind of filter some of that
out but uh but yeah like definitely
needs to be used in cadence like you
said
got it uh when you start to think about
uh this weekend forget bitcoin for a
second we are are we partying this
weekend what's going on with uh school
yeah bro it's it's syllabus week so
no no one's been doing any school stuff
this week i'm sure everybody's ready to
have some fun but uh stay safe out there
hopefully nobody uh gets covered but you
know aside from that i'm i'm ready to
have some fun this weekend
let's go
back in college i love it i love it man
all right listen thank you so much for
doing this uh what is twitter where do
we want to send people and then they can
find the newsletter uh in your twitter
bio
yeah sure thanks for plugging me in as
always man um i'm on twitter at w
clementi iii i'm at 199.1
so if you guys could point me over 200.
this weekend wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're right now at 199
yeah oh hold on a second hold on hold on
hold on
you got to get me right this is what
we're going to do right now ready
so i just put in the chat everyone his
twitter account go follow him and then
let's do this ready
i'm going to
man i can't believe i just got tricked
into doing this but are you ready
the
young
on-chain wizard
will clemente is at
199.9 000
followers
bet you all can't push him over 200k
before the end of
the day
let's see is this gonna work
go follow at will clemente
all right let's see
i just tweeted it i didn't even spell
check or anything so if i spelled
anything wrong whatever
you man let's see what happens well if
you get to 200k then the next stop is a
million so perfect you'll be ready to
rock and roll um
there's one thing you taught me pomp
that's to think big
keep going man you're doing a great job
all right we will we'll see if we can
get you over 200k before the end of the
day and uh i appreciate you coming on we
will we'll see you on next friday don't
have too much fun this weekend
yes sir i'll do my best and you guys
take it easy thanks for having me thank
you thanks will all right see you buddy
guys what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]